one of the hosts of first take on ESPN
every single day from 10:00 a.m. to noon
he's got his own radio show as we all
know on ESPN Radio simulcast on ESPN
news every day between 1:00 and 3:00
Eastern but he's taken the day off from
this to do PTI again with mr. Tony he is
Stephen H Smith how are you doing
Stephen a what's going on race how you
doing buddy how's everything you know I
just needed a little Hollis Queens in my
life that's what I needed
that's all how are you doing how how's
the lovely white kids please give him my
love Susie many people might not know
she and I go back a very very long ways
but I know you know that I do know that
I do know that and Susie sends her best
back to you as well
hey what do you make of Kauai being able
to lift the phone and call Paul Georgia
and then the Oklahoma City situation
just gets blown up should that should
that be something that has some sort of
legislation from the league to prevent
Steven n what do you think I disagree
with that it was definitely an epic move
on a particle while in it make no
mistake about that to be a star of his
caliber to be a two-time NBA Finals
champion NBA champion rather than an NBA
Finals MVP amen to be a free agent to go
to the Los Angeles Clippers and the
basically say look LeBron and AED are in
the Staples Center the same city in the
same town same arena they're playing and
I'm not about to come here and try to
compete with that by myself I've got a
guy that I want to play with but you'll
have to go get him the Los Angeles
Angeles Clippers did not have to
capitulate they had to freedom the pass
dole clomid City Thunder certainly did
not have to capitulate it certainly
didn't benefit them they they could you
know or in terms of losing Paul George
they could have passed they elected not
to and that's the price of doing
business it is what it is when we look
at these guys got to remember Sam Presti
was on the phone contemplating
potentially moving Russell Westbrook and
Paul George to the Toronto Raptors
even though it's a part of the agreement
to contract that the players sign
whereas the players don't sign a
contract that says you know what you can
come in and demand a trade in the event
that you're not happy the reality is the
power still
the team this notion that the players
have the power is something that IBM and
lead disagree with because you don't
have to capitulate you could tell them
to kick rocks they're under contract you
go out there and you perform because we
have you under contract and we have your
rights you could elect to do that it
might not be wise in terms of the kind
of culture it was that would be
compromised or what have you but the
power still lies with the team because
they are the ones that have the
contracts at their disposal they didn't
have to capitulate they elected to and
it turns out that it bode well for them
because they got five first-round picks
and two players the number of times that
I've heard from your colleagues who have
come on this show Ramona Shelburne Wynn
Horst others who are clearly locked in
as well as you that they're like well as
soon as the star player asks out you
just got a you just gotta show them the
door because it just it's very difficult
to have that athlete there and they can
make life difficult for the team I've
never heard of an instance of an NBA
general manager saying no we're not
trading you Stephen a it just seems to
be a contract is different definitely a
different like in the National Football
League got me please I mean we all know
that the power lies with you know the
teams and on their respective owners and
on the ship but in a case of the
National Basketball Association the
players have become brands and
commodities in and of themselves they're
like twelve individual corporations for
crying out loud but understand what that
also means it also means that they have
tremendous value let's again taking that
take Paul George for example Paul George
was a star with the Indiana Pacers that
was flourishing and he was elevating
himself to superstar status when he got
injured in summer league play playing
for Team USA okay then he was out for
year and obviously came back needed to
get his legs under him and then last
year returned the star-studded status
averaging twenty eight and eight it was
his best season rich Ivan didn't know
championship appalled George's resume
there's not even any evidence any proof
that you walked through the turnstile
and sell out arenas for him please don't
get me wrong he's a star he's a
first-class guy all the way but he's not
LeBron James
this is not
some iconic brand that goes overseas and
you know it is like the second coming to
Michael Jackson or Michael Jordan or
somebody like that that kind of status
is reserved for the likes of uh LeBron
James so all I'm saying to you is that
when we look at it from that perspective
you still have to look at it and say
damn they got for unprotected
first-round picks for this guy an
additional protected first-round pick
plus Danilo Gallinari and che Gillis
Alexander who's considered a young
phenom with incredible potential as a
point guard on the National Basketball
Association level for years and years
and years to come
who's only in a secondly you know
there's his rookie campaign so think
about that you got five picks all first
rounders and two starters for one player
and this guy is not even considered the
superstar the likes of a LeBron James or
Kawhi Leonard or even an Anthony Davis
yes
Paul George has incredible value but
keep in mind you did not have to
capitulate what Sam Presti was able to
do was manufacture his presence on the
Oklahoma City thunders roster
contractually and parlayed that into
something incredibly significant in the
eyes of all parties concerned I don't
see where the complaint is I truly don't
Steven Naismith from a Steven a Smith
show on radio and also first take every
day on ESPN from 10:00 a.m. to 2:00 noon
and then of course later on with mr.
Toney on PTI right here on the Rich
Eisen show I give you the Lakers roster
and also coaching staff I give you the
Clippers coaching staff and roster which
one you choose I'm going with the
Clippers I think the Lakers have a
better duo when LeBron and Anthony Davis
but I think the Clippers have a more
complete team Kawhi Leonard is a
superstar in this league he's a top-five
player Paul George is the top-10 player
the two of them together this skills pet
along with their poise and temperament
on the basketball court complements one
another and oh by the way their elite
two-way players they don't just play
often both are accustomed to have in
prime defensive assignments and
answering the call
on the night and night out basis then
you add to that Patrick Beverley who's
arguably the best offensive point guard
in the entire NBA you acquired Mohawk
with ultimately it was on Portland last
year okay and so when you look at it
from that perspective that you still
kept montrezl harrell and Lou Williams
coming off the bench I look at the
Clippers as being a more complete
package
they've got perimeter shooting they're
gonna be an elite defensive team they
got an abundance of Rough Riders on
their squadron scared to anything they
can shoot perimeter shots and the
ultimate x-factor is that they have Doc
Rivers and the Los Angeles Lakers have
Frank Vogel no disrespect to Frank Vogel
he coached the Indiana Pacers to
back-to-back Eastern Conference Finals
appearances years ago his spent in
Orlando was less attractive less
compelling but that's not to say the
band can't coach at all but at no time
in his career was he ever confused would
be in the quality of a coach the quality
of a motivator that is Doc Rivers and I
think you take that all into
consideration and you have to give the
Clippers the edge over the Los Angeles
Lakers who went out you got boogie
cousins and you got Danny Green and you
brought back Rajon Rondo and you kept
calm Kuzma but they still need some
shooters and they and and and I think
that when you look at it from that
perspective I think the Clippers are
better remedy shooters I think the
Clippers are better as defenders and I
think they have better coaching so the
combination of all those things I would
say give them the edge but it is
basketball and they do have the better
dynamic duo and I think Anthony Davis
and LeBron James can change all of that
but the Clippers do should be considered
a better team at this particular moment
in time
did you hear Stephen a that you know the
LA Times reported that uncle Dennis in
Kauai asked magic about his appearance
on your show on first take about what
was going on in the front office and
that might have been part of the reason
why Kauai decided to create his own
super team did you hear about all that
Steve I did not I did not hear about
that but I'm not surprised I think that
if Magic Johnson was still with the Los
Angeles Lakers the
Los Angeles Lakers with about a bit an
opportunity of acquiring Kawhi Leonard
Magic Johnson who I know very well
obviously this was in the works over the
last three years what he had plotted and
planned was to get LeBron first Anthony
Davis second and Kawhi Leonard or Kevin
Durant third that was the plan and then
ultimately things went awry and so I it
wouldn't surprise me at all if Kawhi
Leonard his uncle Dennis asked that
question imagine Johnson knows uncle
Dennis very well he knows one of all
kawatte other friends and sky wilts that
was a UCLA Jeremy West knows them too by
the way and credit to Jerry West but
magic knew these guys obviously robbed a
linker the general manager for the Los
Angeles Lakers had been working to you
know try to figure out some things about
Kawhi Diaz or Steve Fisher who was
collage coaches college at San Diego
State where who coach Rob palinka is
right when he was a reserve on a Fab
Four and so he was trying to use that
connection but ultimately I think that
Kawara wanted to go and play for Doc
Rivers I think he looked at the
billionaire of riches owned in all of
sports and Steve Ballmer he looked at
arguably the greatest executive in the
history of the sport being his
right-hand man to Jerry West he looked
at Lawrence Frank in the front office
their medical staff he looked at Doc
Rivers and he said this is the
first-class organization but the Lakers
were still appealing enough where you
could use that as legitimate black Bell
per se you could use them as leverage to
go back to the Clippers and say if you
don't go and give Paul George I'm gonna
go and play with LeBron James and
Anthony Davis now whether Kawhi Leonard
officially and literally did that Rich
Eisen I believe he did but I don't know
but what I will tell you is this that's
what he told the Clippers that I can
tell you the Clippers were incredibly
incredibly fearful that if they did not
sign Kawhi Leonard he was going to be a
Laker originally weeks leading up to it
I had a couple of members of the
organization saying there was no way in
hell we were going to lose out on Kawhi
Leonard to the Los Angeles Lakers but in
the last 24 hours
they firmly
they were about to lose him to the Los
Angeles Lakers and Steve Ballmer was not
having that and Doc Rivers was not
having that Jerry West was not having
that and that's why they pulled the
trigger before I send you off to ride
home and mr. Tony and that fantastic
group there in DC awesome crew for a PTI
now that the amazing so now that they're
all the chips have pretty much fallen we
don't know if Westbrook is gonna be on
the move or not but I don't think he's
going to go to a team that would
appreciably tell ridge they can't they
can't they can't keep Russell Westbrook
because the message has been sent to
them loudly and clearly that che Gillis
Alexander's incredibly promising but
that his growth would be compromised by
being on the team with Russell Westbrook
so since you're clearly not competing
anyway in OKC you have to make the call
to move Russell Westbrook out of there
which here now officially has welcome
because you're clearly rebuild and
you're going young you stockpiling picks
they just made a pick with with Denver
giving up a player for a first run for
Denver's first-round pick as well
they're gonna use some of those picks to
trial probably try to get somebody to
take Russell Westbrook's for years 107
million remaining on his contract you're
not gonna see people clamoring to take
that straight up they'll want something
with Russell Westbrook and they'll use
those picks to do it fascinating you
think it's Miami Stephen I think Miami's
got a decent shot they want them I can
tell you that they wonder whether or not
they have what it takes to get him
remains to be seen it depends on who's
going to compete the Knicks are going to
try to compete in all likelihood um
clearly Miami wants them if I had to bet
my money I'm certainly not going to bet
against Pat Riley how Russell Westbrook
and Jimmy Butler would work I'm not sure
but here's the reality
Miami is religiously had one of the
highest payrolls in basketball over the
last several years and little to nothing
to show for it at some point in time
you've got to be back in the picture
adding Russell Westbrook as shaky as
that may be in some people's eyes
appearing in with Jimmy Butler if you
add Russell Westbrook in Miami now that
koala
left Mirotic and Brogdon are going from
Milwaukee Al Horford and Kyrie Irving
are gone from Boston and Philadelphia is
looking for a shooter now that they've
lost JJ reddick and Jimmy Butler even
though they added Orford and retained
Tobias Harris the East is perceived as
being wide open and as a result Pat
Riley may sense that and as a result may
pull the trigger because of what Butler
and Westbrook together could potentially
do for them in the Eastern Conference
it may happen the question I was gonna
ask you was West now that the pieces of
landed who do you like to win the West
evening last one for you me I think the
Clippers should be the favorites but I
think if the Clippers or the Lakers I
don't think Portland Utah all of these
teams have improved Newark each is
coming back in Portland yeah Denver
can't be ignored you tall with calmly
and Bogdanovich and boys they're a
threat Houston can't be ignored I'm
still going with the to LA teams one of
them to me are coming out of the West
and I think the NBA Finals next year
will be in LA at the Staples Center I'm
just not sure which team is going to be
well then dinners on me Stephen a
dinner's on me if that happen you know
ah but you know I'm gonna take you up on
that buddy absolutely we're done you've
got it thanks again Susie sends her best
have a great time say hi to Tony and
everybody else there and I look forward
to the next time already appreciate it
Tony Tony just peaked in a sense as best
as well take it easy buddy fantastic you
got it Stephen a Smith for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app